hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to subnautica now we
are in the depths of Hell and that's
okay which is weird to say but it is
okay because we are going to go into the
primary research facility amongst all
the death and destruction that is down
here we do have that to look forward to
but before I do that I don't have enough
resources to be able to build more
lockers so I just got to read names but
anyway thank you to jf xam who said
Marcus big box Barre is about to blow up
be sure to get you in your prawn suit
because you'll loop lose anything that's
docked if the subs health reaches here
you can salvage Cyclops parts but not
salvage what was docked and I don't
think that matters anyway because I lose
this I've lost everything if I lose this
I might as well start over which I
practically will be doing so I'm going
to make a very concerted effort not to
lose this hi how are you doing buddy
and then there's Mark does stuff success
mark don't think of these as caves think
of it as a mouth of a really really big
monster and I am thinking of that now
and thank you I didn't want to think of
that thank you very much then that guy
yet again says mark I swear every time
you get that perfect x pants pissing it
just makes the frantic yelling worth it
well thank you I'd like to think that
the game is programmed to respond to my
freaking out nature and then gaming
remor teh said you should totally in the
series by going scuba diving deep in the
ocean and you know what that actually
sounds pretty fun if I was actually able
to do that go to one of those shark
cages and just sit in the bottom of the
ocean kind of figure out a way to film
that and piss my pants a whole lot I'll
have a water reclamation suit after all
but anyway enough skedaddling around we
got to go into here and i don't know why
it's so dark all of a sudden I don't
know I can't see anything it is like
pitch-black and I don't know why sahrin
is gonna move he he ha ha ha ha try the
camera system uh oh my god
what happened it's so dark it's so dull
hey hey hey
hey hey I am rigged for silent running
you could not do that that'd be great Oh
ah what am i heading we're fine we're
fine everything's fine
oh I don't like that I don't know where
the Leviathan went where did love ie go
burn at the Dargan go ah oh this place
is horrible this place is the worst kind
of place where is he
oh I okay not necessary buddy oh oh
there you are
I'm headed straight for you Oh God
okay huh huh we got to get in there I'm
gonna sneak around I've got the blue key
I've got the blue key I've got the blue
key which I've been told is for this
thing hey hey hey hey enough all right
No oh boy whew that is a slow lazy
circling my oh hi okay all right I am
silently running oh don't look at me
Oh golly gee how there's so much life
down here with this [ __ ] Oh God oh
that guy got please take a cab eat into
the into the primary residual you're not
coming ha ha oh that guy got annihilated
highway ok we're fine ok he seems to be
going over there was my chance to go in
here sorry warper you're about to get
Wham do
Oh so many for peace where there are so
many warmers oh boy I don't know if I'm
gonna make it here I'm gonna try yeah hi
okay hello hi go away please
little boy oh boy everyone is getting a
little sassy today now okay get that
sweet little too tightly there oh boy
okay all right you're fine you're fine
and I'm fine we're fine together oh okay
I thought he was coming for me
Oh screaming a little loud okay I think
we're in position so if I go down get my
blue a my silently running I better I
bet I better be rigged for okay good I
am huh all right I just need to go down
grab the key get in there yeah that's
all I need to do should I take my prom
suit that probably a good idea probably
good idea let me just drop off some of
the [ __ ] I got in here oh okay so this
is all I need I should be good to go big
box Barry been a while right if I don't
make it back well try to get home
without me don't know if you can but if
you can try go for it I'm just gonna
save one last time before I go out of
here
oh all right let's do this key opti
thank you oh don't do that oh no oh no
oh no oh no oh no don't do this
you've done this before don't do this
again so you need the point then you
boys don't do that to me hey [ __ ]
high who did that
oh hi Oh
no no no no I will fight you to the
death
whoa let me out here whoa boy ping ping
ping ping ping ping
no Miami huh oh [ __ ] huh
okay so I don't see I don't see an
access panel anywhere around here ah
all right I don't see an access panel
but I see things in there which is
different than it was before so I'm
gonna go in there I just got to figure
out how I guess I also need to fix up
this guy sorry big guy didn't mean for
you get it hurt like that okay you see
oh oh as easy as that they don't have
any base here so all I did was use this
same thing I used for the Aurora hi what
the hell is that about okay man that guy
is angry that I'm getting in here okay
so what I should use as a disclaimer is
to say that everything in here is
temporary so I'm not going to
permanently be in here because it's not
it's not for me yeah unless I have a
compelling reason not to oh my god okay
ah yes
ah oh hi sorry to be interrupting around
here but I'm just you know curious about
what's going on
hop out that's a giant thing ion
crystals that I could get if I wanted
but I don't know if I necessarily want
to because I kind of want to make
everything temporary for now emperor
project data
let me just say this device records data
from the primary research specimen of
this facility according to the logs an
indigenous life-form referred to as the
Emperor specimen was found to produce a
unique substance they referred to as
enzyme 42 which inhibited the symptoms
of the infection in other indigenous
organisms the specimen was captured and
contained here in addition to the eggs
it was found guarding the alien
researchers went to great lengths to
provide for the forms environmental
needs including the import of
interdependent flora and fauna via the
on-site warpgate however its health
quickly began to deteriorate at the time
of the bacterial outbreak and result in
quarantine all attempts to develop the
EM design into a vaccine had been
unsuccessful fascinating I wonder why
that is okay alright then you do what
you need to do I really do wonder why
that is why would there be nothing for
that what is this I don't know shall I
scan you Whaley and relic the markings
on this device seemed to serve no
purpose beyond decoration and maybe the
alien equivalent of a lamp or magnifying
glass used to examine other relics in
more detail alrighty then
fancy there was this one another lamp
Yusei see despite its simple design this
device contains enough potential energy
to destroy the entire planet the most of
the solar system fortunately it is
malfunctioned so why is it why is it on
display here oh the aliens trying to do
little weird and this one looks like
some kind of bug Oh
or a turn this rock-like material
features biomechanical parts that match
components identified in the war pers
accounted in four five or six B
materials such as this may even have
been fundamental building block of the
aliens own self repairing mechanisms
interesting I call it a turd an alien
turd is what there seems like it seems
like a museum for someone that doesn't
know what's going on here it is unclear
why technology of the sophistication has
not been found elsewhere on the planet
its production may have been restricted
or too costly or it may have been
pillaged from a more ancient
civilization that's weird to think about
just a continuing like train of
different older alien civilizations here
I mean it's entirely possible this alien
device appears to be designed to
eliminate all organic substances and
arranged by emitting the lethal but
contained radioactive field I good I'm
going to assume that's good and
everyone's going to be happy when that
happens I'm just kind of gone through
this methodically I don't know which
one's gonna lead to where but I'm just
gonna go in each door kind of find out
for myself
oh ah that's oh these must all be doors
that lead to individual warp gate Oh
insert fuel crystal well time to go
harvest some fuel crystals I guess
didn't know that now okay didn't know
that I need to do that at least I can
crack them open right here in the center
and be enough to fuel all the warp gates
which is really really fascinating
because holy [ __ ] okay can i oh I didn't
need to jump apparently good news skeet
don't mind me just finding up some
nuclear material here super-powerful
very fragile stuff could blow up
everything to blow up absolutely
everything
yep the pink diamonds are enough to dis
shatter this to pieces is the crux of
all your alien technology let me just
lay a hammer into it for my own personal
gain no I'm gonna complain right so once
I get a second put these into the
teleporters and then activate it but
again I don't know if I want to do this
all yet because this is all temporary
because it's not ready yet it it just
like it's cool why is that like why I
don't know okay okay did I get them all
Oh unlimited unlimited are you kidding
me unlimited oh my god this more relics
over there I'll get those in a second
put on limited ah it wasn't temporary oh
god I would I would okay let me just go
back here I'm gonna see what the [ __ ] is
up with this and I'm gonna see where it
goes
cuz if I can go in it I kind of want to
see where it leads me uh no idea
skadoosh woo yeah oh that's that's a
little off oh my god so that's why I
could never power them because they were
never powered from the other side whoa
okay well I went around the wall
hello whoa this is the alien research
one is just what this one is
Oh oh that's so cool oh that's so cool I
will go back in just a second I just
want to see exactly where I am I'm 600
meters down so I must be in the Lost
River which must mean this is the Lost
River Research Facility right but I
don't remember this being here I don't
remember any of this being here oh oh
that's the same thing sorry oh no I
remember this I think maybe I don't know
I don't know I know this isn't my
primary objective right now but I'm just
too curious oh my god oh oh that's so
weird I don't even know what that is oh
that's so cool but now ah but I don't ah
god it's just ah
I'm trying to exercise a little bit of
self-discipline here because it's not
it's not ready it's not ready it's not
ready because this is supposed to be the
end of the game like this area the alien
research facility or the primary
research facility is supposed to be the
absolute end of the game ah I pissed
myself it was so exciting
ah but if it is the end of the game then
I want to make sure that it's actually
like all said and done before I actually
do it so I'm assuming that all of these
chambers in here is going to hurt again
now why did I do that but all of these
chambers in here must lead to other
teleporters right that's what they are
so I don't need to go to all the whole
well this one this one's different was
oh okay just bleeding through a little
bit don't mind anything err Oh a little
bit unfinished that's why I said it's
not finished
whew this device records all available
physical data from a single point in
time the last recorded data set was
captured just after quarantine was
imposed on the facility specimen data
the main containment chamber here housed
the CM / Leviathan and it's eggs the
parent leviathans health have
deteriorated it - eggs appeared to be in
good condition but in some
form of natural stasis alien structures
the data shows that within the vast
specimen contained unit an incubation
system had been constructed to house the
leviathans eggs likely the alien
researchers have refocused their efforts
to develop a vaccine on the unborn
infants the incan Basin system
incubation system suggests they had
resorted to developing artificial
hatching enzymes which would stimulate
the natural hatching environment when
quarantine was imposed all warped gates
and access points to the facility were
sealed
while the unborn emperor specimens may
have held some potential for the
development of vaccine it is highly
unlikely that parent or child survived
having their food supply cut off and
being isolated from the rest of their
ecosystem fascinating fascinating in
this dark unlit room of which I don't
want to be here but that's also super
cool because it's like it's talking
about this was a thousand years ago so
that's how these eggs survived the only
way to survive was because they had a
natural stasis and this must be another
warp gate but I just want to be certain
like maybe the side chambers are yeah it
is
oh but I don't I might as well activate
it you know you never know maybe I just
feel so bad I don't want to go I don't
want to do it all yet ah oh well you
know it's here I better stop warring
with myself about it you know I've never
let it stop me before if I see something
that wasn't ready yet because I didn't
let that spoil the end experience
because that's what this is about what
about the end experience seeing where it
goes and where it'll take and that's
what it is
Oh a sword huh that's awfully softly
ancient
huh the in ancient earth blade earth
blade dated back to the 13th century
Mongolian Empire blood samples on the
blade matched the DNA of seven separate
heads of state from the period why is
there an earth blade here are these are
these just all relics from different
alien civilizations that looks like yin
and yang carving is a hundred of that
hundreds of thousands of years old and
made from an unrecognized natural fiber
likely grown on and as yet undiscovered
planet so these aliens they were
researchers they were Explorer
they were just exploring the galaxy
trying to find things whoa
this weapon appears to be millions of
years old and matches no previously
encountered technologies it's weird cuz
it look so simple that bizarre but you
know enough to know it's a weapon I
guess alien reliquary that's just the
holding tank that it's in cases composed
of an impregnable translucent metal at
the distant end of the periodic table
scans do not reveal any contents rightie
Haven is this lovely thing beautiful
this device is a rudimentary version of
the keys used to access these facilities
it may have been kept here for symbolic
purposes or legacy support interesting
so they developed new tech while they
were here I mean that's what they must
do they must just Salvage other tech
this device for some point of
communications relay apparently the
objecting the presence of the user to a
remote location there do not seem to be
any other devices in range oh so just a
communicator okay oh I was about to say
that looked on vanished okay I'm gonna
worry about the teleporters later I just
want to see if there's like something
else here that I can get let me just
drink some gas and I'll wait for the
food block that's a last resort
unfinished no not unfinished whoa
and what in der hack is deuce whoa some
kind of pumping system probably for the
arms right for the prize for the tank
that they use for the Emperor this
machinery is pumping water to and from
the attached pipe Network
oxygen-deprived water is being flooded
from the system analysis of the water
composition flowing it indicates it is
being drawn from different biomes
between here and the surface of the
planet the water temperature is
considerably lower than the volcanic
environment outside the facility and
oxygen-rich you mean to tell me okay
this is this is astonishing if you think
about it you mean to tell me they have
pipes through the entire planet just for
pumping water number one how did they
dig the holes to be able to put in the
pipes and number two how did they place
the pipes after they dug the holes how
did they do that I mean of all the
technological marvelous things oh
there's more down there of all the
things that I've seen thus far that kind
of raises a lot of questions and I don't
have any answers to that oh and where
did this come I mean I know there's
going to be like a long episode because
there is so much to explore in here oh
my god that's not even done yet that's
the crazy thing it's not done yet oh
it's huge oh that's not done either okay
well peer into the face of death oh my
god oh my god that's so far down hey
buddy how you doing down there
you stuck yeah that you are okay besides
the other two teleporters that means
there's only one more place to go or
maybe two more places I don't know this
place is so confusing you never know
which way you're going to go what I
think I think I may be close to getting
to the actual place where the Emperor
his house which is really cool alright
okay so there's that place right there
which is the thing and there's up there
so what is over here whoa what is that
okay hang on I'll come back for that
because I don't want to use the unlock
doors command just yet because I don't
want to be disappointed or get there too
soon because there's something else up
here it kind of leads towards the front
of the building I don't know what it is
but it's B whoa
okay ha what is is supposed to be in
here hmm it whispers in my mind what is
this oh these are the eggs oh and this
one either got broken or it hatched what
the hell Oh shell composition the shell
casing is formed of thick layers of
carbon composites suggesting an
extensive gestation period the Leviathan
species may give birth just once per
century perhaps just once in their
lifetimes precise incisions suggest a
laser based tool was used to cut open
the egg case and enforceable IRRI move
the fetus inside prior to full gestation
time pressure to develop a bacterial
vaccine may have driven the alien
researchers to cut open this egg and
remove the fetus for study ha god that's
scary and it is also possible that
removed from its parent and natural
habitat some vital condition for the
infant to hatch naturally was not met
interesting so it's safe to say that
these these fetuses probably did not
slow hi okay that is suspect okay hi
okay dad that's weird
don't know why that's happening okay I'm
just going to get out of here because
that's freaking weird okay so that that
is really fascinating that's really
fascinating super weird but anyway
there's only one more place to go and
I'm going to go there right about now
funk soul brother oh there it goes
that's weird it's weird weird okay and
we go
oh and again I'm very sorry for to all
vaccine development program terminated
emperor egg hatching project terminated
live specimens terminated evacuate
immediately
oh well that doesn't sound very good
that sounds bad
period Oh what the [ __ ] what happens if
I just don't in there
hey Oh Howie Oh Allie oh maybe it was a
bad idea to jump in here maybe it was a
bad idea maybe this was a bad idea
oh I'm gonna say this is a bad idea oh
boy what am I still in the water what do
I give the girdle okay I heard a little
gurgle and I didn't like that but okay
well okay skidoo Sookie okay so either
either I go up there and I try to unlock
that door or I go through here swings
wrong Georgia the dumb jungle baby whoa
not quite
hope okay oh there's nothing here
ah that's why it's just a wall let me
try this just in case yeah it's just a
wall whoa hello uh-huh hi oh hi hello oh
hi hello hi hi hello hi hello hi okay
all right that's weird
oh wow oh oh okay okay okay oh oh oh
Oh big guy okay all right hi oh that's
so cool oh that's so cool
oh it's so cool and so scary you're huge
oh that's cool though hi oh my god and
hang on I'm about to run out of oxygen
I brought my uh I brought my pron suit
over here for just such an occasion
oh my god okay all right then hey you
brewski hello hello hello
okay Clippers captain okay all right
seasons it's so weird
it's so okay all right hi hello okay I'm
just gonna fall I guess I'm gonna be
able to get out of here now but okay oh
boy
[ __ ] oh those your eggs
Oh Oh
that is frickin hair flying that is
terrifying
and those are huge oh those are huge ion
crystals oh my god
that's so weird and these are your eggs
these are you guys detecting unusually
passive behavioral patterns and nearby
predators reason unknown oh don't look
at me like that
oh don't look at me like that oh hi
hello are you coming in
oh hi hello hi Heidi Heidi Heidi oh okay
oh boy oh hi all right hello oh hi oh oh
scary
wow that's scary oh that's terrifying
do you want me to use this
you want me to oh oh I didn't bring
those oh I didn't bring those hatching
enzymes mysterious enzymes from
creepvine sample oh I don't have that oh
my god oh man that's so weird what would
happen if you use this if I actually
brought creepvine down here and use them
with the hatching enzymes like what
would I do
I was so weird what do you say
Chell uncommon ly strong shell lining
organic growth on the x-series suggests
these eggs may be hundreds of years old
alien devices penetrate the outer layer
of the she'll likely designed to supply
them with nutrients and isolate them
from the surrounding environments unlike
most eggs where a nutrient supply is
slowly exhausted by the embryo these
eggs exist in a form of natural stasis
likely awaiting ideal hatching
conditions fetal organism there's a high
genetic match between these organisms in
the Leviathan in the vicinity they
appear to be stable and healthy it is
likely that ideal hatching conditions
vary considerably from ideal conditions
for survival of the parents the local
ecosystems appears to have prioritized
elaborate weird all that look it out so
weird oh man oh man the Jambo hi hello
okay all right then
see ya ah so you are waiting to see what
I would do to the eggs
ah so what would happen if I did this
would it mean anything if I did this now
I don't know and that's the thing right
I don't know because all of this is
unfinished like even this it tastes
wrong you know what I mean because I
didn't earn this yet I didn't earn any
of this I don't know what all this means
because I didn't get here like
legitimately and he's coming back just
to say hi to me because I'm he's waiting
to see what I could do but it feels
wrong you know what I mean I'm right on
the cusp of something here and I I I
can't bring myself to go get hatching
enzymes and do this because it's not
here yet
and I'm not going to cheat and get him
like I'm not refused to do that I've
already cheated enough thus far and this
all ties in to why I said this was ten
rarey i said in the beginning of this
episode i said that this was temporary
and here's why i'm going to make a
decision that's going to be very
unpopular popular with a lot of people
but i have reasons for it when i set out
to make this new adventure in subnautica
about what is it 40 50 episodes ago i
set out to do this because i wanted to
experience everything everything there
was in subnautica and the tragic thing
about it is that it is early access and
that means that things are unfinished
again i set out on a journey that was
futile in the beginning because it was
not all there and i had some hopes that
they might finish the game but the game
is not released yet and even here right
on the precipice of what could
potentially be the end of the game it
doesn't feel right if I were to get
enzymes cheat with them and see that
right then and there and you know why
it's because I wouldn't have earned it
the beautiful thing about me playing
this game up until this point is that I
had earned everything and I felt so bad
in the past three episodes that I've had
the cheat to unlock doors because I
didn't earn that it didn't feel right it
wasn't right because it wasn't ready and
I've pushed some boundaries getting in
here because I know you guys wanted to
be in this room with that si Emperor and
seeing what happens when you hatch these
eggs but to be perfectly honest I don't
think anything would because it's not
done and it's not ready and I don't know
for certain if it is or isn't but I'm
going to end this here this is it for
subnautica for now and I know that's sad
to hear and it's sad for me to say
because I've had so much fun on this
journey but I've had fun on it because
of the way I did it and because of the
the like amazing things that I saw along
the way and because of the hardships
that I had to go through to be able to
get to this point that's what makes
games fun
it's a fantastic world and you have to
earn it that's the beautiful thing
behind it and that's what makes it so
sad when you have to say goodbye you
know I mean this Emperor is looking at
me looming over me in huge the biggest
thing I've seen yet in the game and I
cannot cheat I will not cheat and I will
not even go out and get this stuff and
see if it will work here not because of
the time it'd be easy with the
teleporters but just because it's not
ready so this is the end of the road for
me in subnautica I know there's been a
long speech I didn't prepare it or
anything but I just wanted to justify to
you guys why I am setting subnautica
down for now because it is not done it's
all temporary but it will be done soon
when the game goes live and it actually
has an ending when it actually has
everything done here I will revisit this
game but until then I have to say
goodbye for now and again I know that's
not going to make a lot of people happy
but it's what's right and it'll be even
better when you earn it when I earn that
ending when I earn what's here when I
earn this
like when I earn the answers to all the
questions in my mind when I earn them
it'll be so much more satisfying and
it'll be so cool but don't worry I'm not
when I pick it back up I'm not going to
start a new game and it's not going to
be another 50 episodes that's why I said
everything was temporary I'm not going
to save after this I'm going to end it
here and I'm a restart back in the old
save make sense it should be well worth
the wait so thank you everybody so much
for watching let me know what you think
of this down in the comments below and
as always I will see you in the next
video bye bye